good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight october surprise you've
heard that term
it's political slang for a damaging news
story that appears in the final days of
a campaign
this year we had won one of the biggest
october surprises
ever the new york post that's the oldest
daily newspaper in this country
published a trove of documents showing
that members of joe biden's
family have been selling access to the
former vice president to a number of
foreign governments
including the communist government of
china that's a blockbuster
but the rest of the media decided to
kill it before you could read it
social media companies banned their
users from sharing the new york post's
reporting
other news organizations simply ignored
it on october 22 that was 11 days before
the presidential election
national public radio or an organization
that is literally state media funded
against your will by your tax dollars
issued the following statement through
its public editor npr explained
that they would not say anything
negative about the bidens and here's why
quote we don't want to waste our time on
stories that are not really stories and
we don't want to waste the listeners and
readers time
on stories that are just pure
distractions end quote
now you're probably thinking that is the
single dumbest
most dishonest high-handed infuriatingly
arrogant thing i have ever heard
but if you feel that way obviously you
don't watch cnn
on that same day october 22nd an rnc
spokeswoman called liz harrington
made the mistake of submitting to an
interview with christian amanpour
harrington had hoped to talk about the
biden's business deals
amanpour is and we're quoting here cnn's
chief
international anchor here's how it went
as you know perfectly well i'm a
journalist and a reporter and i follow
the facts
and there has never been any issues in
terms of corruption now let me ask you
this
yesterday the fbi wait wait wait how do
you know that
i'm talking about reporting and any
evidence
i'm talking to you now okay if you guys
would start doing that digging and start
doing that verification no we're not
going to do your work for you
i want to ask you a question the fbi
journal is a contrary
it's a journal to find out if this is
verified
as you know perfectly well i am a
journalist and a reporter
says christian amanpour who of course is
neither of those things
and never has been christian amanpour is
a celebrity script reader
a half wit whose self-esteem far
outpaces her accomplishments
she is also it turns out the personal
flack for the biden family international
finance corporation
that's not in her twitter bio but it's
pretty obvious there have never been
any issues of corruption with the bidens
amanpour announced
as if she hadn't just been confronted
with some
and so it went just like that across the
entire american news media
until the presidential election now six
weeks later
it is finally safe to speak freely and
so the truth is coming out
we now know the new york post was right
all along and so was poor liz harrington
of the rnc
yesterday millions of americans learned
some for the very first time
that the biden family has indeed been
deeply enmeshed in a series of sleazy
international business deals that
undercut america's core interests
we learned there is an active federal
criminal investigation into joe biden's
son hunter for that very reason what's
interesting is how we found this out
the media didn't tell us neither did the
justice department
iron biden has far better connections
than say roger stone
hunter biden was allowed to tell his own
story he wasn't rousted from bed at 5 00
am by dozens of armed paramilitaries
his arrest and his boxer shorts carried
live on cnn no no
he's a prominent democrat so he spared
those humiliations
instead the biden harris transition team
broke the news in the form of a
bizarre press release that informed us
with a straight face
that joe biden was quote deeply proud of
his boy hunter
who by the way may have had some minor
tax trouble that he will clear up soon
the minute his accountant returns from
cabo but no big deal
happy holidays okay guys thanks for the
heads up
but actually and you may have guessed
this part turns out there's more
a report in politico today reveals that
joe biden's younger brother
jimmy is involved too this was a family
business keep in mind
jimmy biden is also under federal
criminal investigation for corruption in
the hospital business
we don't know more than that and we
should stress that fast jimmy biden is
presumed innocent until proven otherwise
in a court of law by a jury of his peers
jimmy is not a felon yet we will keep
you updated
for the few who are able to follow the
details of the biden's business deals
back in october who actually read the
new york post series or watch this show
none of this comes as a complete
surprise at the time we talked to tony
babilinski
about what he saw bobolinsky was a
business partner of the bidens as they
tried to weedle money from companies
connected to communist china
tony babilinski by contrast was a
legitimate international businessman
and at some point he began to wonder
what the hell is going on
in our interview bob lindsey described
one of his meetings with fast jimmy
biden
bobalinski wanted to know why the biden
family was so brazen so open
about peddling joe's influence to
oligarchs and enemies of the united
states wasn't that a risk
here's how jimmy biden responded
and i remember looking at jim biden and
saying how are you guys
getting away with this like or aren't
you concerned
and he sort of looked at me and he
laughed a little bit and said
plausible deniability he said that out
loud
uh yes he said it directly to me one on
one in a cabana at the peninsula hotel
plausible deniability when your business
partner tells you
that your business strategy rests on
plausible deniability
that's not reassuring and it certainly
wasn't reassuring to tony bobolinski why
would it be
an independent media wouldn't be fooled
by plausible deniability either they
demand answers what exactly were you
doing
let's see the documents but they didn't
when the new york post published the
outlines of this story the media
raced to find its own plausible
deniability some reason any reason
not to report the story any reporter who
broke
rank and decided to state the facts
was quickly disciplined and brought to
heal
politico's jake sherman for example
apologized in public for the crime of
discussing the new york post story
after twitter suspended him for posting
it for posting facts quote
i tweeted a link to the new york post
story right after it dropped yesterday
morning
i immediately reached out to the biden
campaign to see if they had any answer
i wish i had given the story a closer
read before i tweeted it
in other words bless me cena and for i
have sinned
over at cbs news a kid called bo
erickson didn't get the memo
on the boundaries of this new journalism
so he tried to get joe biden himself to
respond to the story and here's how it
went
i know you'd ask it i have no response
it's another smear campaign
right up your alley they're the
questions you always ask
yeah you're a smear merchant says joe
biden to a guy he's never seen before
and doesn't recognize everyone looks the
same to joe biden it's all kind of a
blur
but he attacked bo erickson of cbs news
as a
liar and a propagandist and what's so
interesting
is that none of bo erickson's colleagues
in the news media came to his defense
in fact several former flags for barack
obama
mocked him on social media and again his
colleagues
stayed silent now we're being told to
pretend that none of this ever happened
it's all down the memory hole
in an article published today in the
daily beast probably the single
worst example of bad journalism on the
internet
we learned that quote evidence of the
larger hunter biden probe was apparent
in the markings on a series of documents
that were made public
but went largely unnoticed in the days
leading up to the november election
largely unnoticed of course middle of
the presidential campaign
front page story about one of the
candidates doing business with our main
global enemy
but somehow nobody noticed just weird
unaccountable how'd that happen
one group who did notice were the
professional liars in our so-called
intel community the ones that work
hand-in-glove with so-called journalists
in our media
shortly after the new york post story
ran a number of these people
all-star propagandists like jim clapper
and john brennan
people who've lied in public under oath
and never been punished for it
they denounced the new york post series
as soviet-style disinformation
the stories they said had quote all the
classic earmarks of a russian
information operation they didn't
explain what that meant but they didn't
need to the media class ate it up
like the seals they are they clapped and
barked in unison russia
russia russia he is receiving
and is now regurgitating repeating and
disseminating
disinformation that he knows to be
fabricated
and supplied by a foreign intelligence
service and despite the warning
he's still doing it you have said this
entire thing is so
obviously a russian plot it is to me and
i was never
even a ambassador to the russian
federation
tell me why it's so obviously a russian
plot to you rudy basically functioning
as a russian asset
by pushing russian disinformation cnn
reported on friday that u.s authorities
are seeing
if those emails we just talked about are
connected to an ongoing russian
disinformation effort huh
yeah it's just obviously a russian plot
obviously obviously none of these people
should ever appear on television again
no doubt was they will
some are saying tonight we need to go
farther to find out what actually
happened there are calls tonight for a
new special prosecutor to investigate
what we have learned so far
about the biden family's business
dealings abroad
now let's be honest as much as we are
anxious to find out the truth and we
think it's important to
a special prosecutor is something that
no one in this country should be eager
to see no matter what side you're on
we've seen over the past four years what
a special prosecutor
can do to the normal functioning of a
government open-ended investigations of
politicians are hallmarks of corrupt
regimes and dictatorships
and most americans are skeptical of
those kinds of probes and rightly so
but unless our media start doing its job
and telling us what our politicians are
up to the just department and bill barr
may have no choice
and if they do move forward with a
special prosecutor they will have one
unlikely supporter
joe biden himself last year joe biden
went on the record confirming that he
would not interfere with
any justice department investigation
look i would not
direct my justice department like this
president does
i'd let them make their independent
judgment i would not
dictate who should be prosecuted or who
should be
exonerated that's not the role of the
president of the united states
follow the law let the justice
department make the judgment
as to whether or not someone should be
prosecuted period
uh-huh we'll see if he lives up to that
we should note if the current president
was quote
directing the justice department for
political ends
he didn't do a very effective job of it
robert mueller spent millions of dollars
spent years ruined many lives
purely as a favor to people who could
not believe that donald trump really
beat hillary clinton
this country might not survive another
investigation like that
on the other hand you've got to wonder
how long a democracy can survive
a leadership class like the one we have
now